voilà alors quand je vous parlais d'une
surprise tout à l'heure la voici la
surprise
vous ne vous rendez peut-être pas tout à
fait compte de la taille mais là vous
allez vous en rendre compte en nous
voyant c'est le plus gros joueur du
monde bernard alors françois avec la
chaque mardi nous il va pas s'en aller 1
comment s'appelle-t-il c'est un capybara
un capybara c'est le plus gros rongeur
du monde qui vit en amérique du sud
il doit peu à peu près 50 kg c'est très
lourd c'est très dense ouais c'est un
animal qui vit actuellement c'est pas un
animal préhistorique il à nantes en tout
cas sa vie en troupeau d'une vingtaine
d'individus qui s'en va mais la liberté
et ils vivent en liberté il adore l'eau
ces animaux qui plombe
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon aussi pour
les animaux passer vos neurones les
animaux qui plonge
n'en sais rien il m'a juste aspergé de 2
litres de peep-toe damas
et alors allez y continuez vous employez
des planteurs ont parfois le caresser
oui c'est ça c'est bon je vous avais pas
testé rejet de mon parti ne fait pas
attention on n'est pas
oui alors allez-y faites votre
commentaire donc c'est un animal c'est
un animal qui vit
doucement doucement 12 foot au
championnat c'est un animal qui vit en
amérique du sud
c'est à cette image
ça va bien mais bon modèle présenté à
tellement peu sinon pas qu'il est
allemand
quand il faudra peut-être faire tout
petit roman devrait pas faire moins de
bruit pour éviter de les choyer parce
qu'il faudrait pas non plus qu'il soit
malheureux
voilà si on se calme après je pense que
l'animal qui est iranien qui vit qui vit
au parc zoologique de thoiry qui est
habitué à voir du monde mais au
contraire il est absolument pas pleurer
puisqu'il n'a pas peur du spot n'a pas
peur des caméras bon il va s'engager un
peu quoi le web en formule habituelle
vivre en liberté à l'avouer
donc il ya pas de pas de prof c'est un
peu mouvementée au lycée mais bon je
voulais simplement remettre mon ciré moi
vous l'auriez dit je serai bien
simplement profité pour donner quelques
conseils sur les rongeurs sont bons
puisque les rangeant sa que celui là
c'est quand même oui il vaut mieux
prévoir d'appartements caractère légal
alors